now Union is starring alongside Oscar
winner Octavia Spencer in the new season
of the crime drama truth be told Spencer
plays a true crime podcast host who
teams up with the high school principal
played by Union to investigate the
missing black girls in their Community
here's a preview
had so long to protect my students but
it wasn't enough
[Music]
it doesn't sound foolish
and yet Drea's still dead
seeing her killer won't change that
just look into his eyes understand his
monstrosity I would know would I failed
to warn my girls against
[Music]
two great actors sharing the scene and
Oscar and Octavia Spencer she she
reached out to you personally Gabrielle
Union for this role yes
um were you hesitant to accept it I was
nervous because of the subject matter
and not sure just how I would react to
to Really mining some of the most
traumatic experiences of my life
for my art and for such a long time you
know such a long period of time for
filming and but I mean it's Octavia you
can't say no to Octavia and we've been
friends for so long this is actually our
third time working together
um and I trust her you know there's not
a lot of people that I trust my peace
and my sanity to but one of those would
be Octavia and I think this season the
work that we've done and the
um the the the spotlight that we've been
able to put on human trafficking sexual
trafficking of young and black brown
girls and and the disparity and media
coverage
um and just the lack of resources that
we put towards the most marginalized of
the marginalized so for all of that it's
worth it you've talked about that
publicly when you talk about the things
that have been dark or difficult for you
uh recently you came up on 30 years
since you were sexually assaulted how do
you think that experience sort of
prepared you for this role or you were
able to sort of bring out certain
emotions
um because of that
well because I was a this the show is
about sexual violence of young people in
the Bay Area at 19 I experienced sexual
violence I was raped at gunpoint at my
job
um
and I thought I had really
I was very clear about everything that
had happened but throughout the filming
of this show I realized the depths of
disassociation so when it was happening
when I've been describing this for 25
years right when it was happening I I
left my body and that is what they call
disassociation sort of removing yourself
you know mentally from where you're at
but I thought I came back into myself
you know by the time the police arrived
right but throughout the filming of this
show what I realized is that for 30
years I thought I knew everything that
had happened
but my mind was protecting me and so
over those five months it was like my
brain was pulling back the curtain on
everything and smells
um gosh like like everything that
happened the the what is what his skin
wow felt like all of it was finally
revealed to me for 30 30 years I thought
I knew
um and what I realized is that
I wouldn't have survived at 19
understanding the enormity of the trauma
and when I think about it I was raped
one time
one time and 30 years later I'm still
struggling right
victims of sexual violence experience
this over and over and over again
indefinitely until they decide you have
no more value and that's why you want to
do this story it's important you want to
work with Octavia Spencer but hearing
you describe I mean this is about sexual
violence in the Bay Area you were a
survivor of sexual violence in the Bay
Area so playing this character must have
been difficult when the cameras are not
rolling I struggled to get through the
nights I cried and I'm not a weepy
person at all at all and I would go home
every night and I would cry and my
husband is like
what's happening
and it was like
finally feeling the full brunt of my
rape and having to use that pain for art
for the greater good and I and I just
felt such an enormous responsibility and
I wasn't exactly prioritizing myself I
just didn't I didn't factor that into
the the work experience to the point
where my friends scheduled a rebirth on
the day that the Show wrapped and I
literally went from set to Malibu and I
got to the beach and I hear these you
know West African drummers and the
elders basically welcoming in welcoming
me into the woman that I'm going to be
so I can finally release this trauma and
because that's how that's how deep the
the wounds go when you experience sexual
violence as a young person and if if my
little experience in comparison to the
enormity of the trauma that these that
these folks experience as as victims of
sexual trafficking where they will blame
you they will make you complicit in your
own abuse
you know what I mean like I was raped at
gunpoint at work and they still asked me
what I had on as though that matters as
though that matters it's it's the
language that we use it's it's the lack
of media attention it's the lack of
resources 71
000 black girls under 17 went missing in
2021 and they were they were identified
as runaways nine out of ten were
identified as runways if you're
identified as a runaway no Amber Alert
or no no no law enforcement attention
nothing having covered Gabby potito on
the ground and knowing that this has
brought more awareness to that issue
we're talking about it more than I could
ever recall as a journalist
um how much do you think the show has
helped with that conversation I mean
we've only been out a few days
um but already the response has been
enormous and we have heard from every
organization
um that does this work you know
Grassroots to the to the big
organizations that are Thanking us for
shining a light on the on the disparity
the massive massive disparity in media
attention even how it's framed right you
know saying things like juvenile
prostitutes juveniles means children
right children cannot consent to sex
work right their children yeah but black
and brown girls get adultified
like we are demonized and we are blamed
for our own abuse which means you're not
going to take it as seriously our
innocence is never
um guaranteed
right it's always up for debate and the
media decides who holds importance which
is why we know about Gabby we know that
hashtag we know all of those hashtags 71
000 yeah name name one hashtag who do we
know when you think about your own
children are you glad you did this for
them from my children for all the for
everybody we need to understand this is
this is an epidemic a global epidemic I
mean 71 000 when you think about the
over 18. that was uh 19 19 500. in in
2020 alone black women who went missing
um
where is the concern where is the care
where's the outrage this is insane
that's why projects are important yeah
just wiped off and and being being
subjected to unspeakable Horrors yeah
well we're turning a blind eye yeah
Gabrielle thank you so much we
appreciate you you can watch the new
season truth be told Apple TV plus new
episodes drop every Friday